Guys,
you don't need to be afraid,
the Palestinian flag may be carried
and be shown
and also so 1 scarf is allowed.
We'll ask the police again in a minute.
But as you can see here
flags are carried everywhere
and it's not a problem at all.
We just asked the police,
unfortunately they do not want to be interviewed,
but which you can also understand.
But they said that it is allowed
to wear the Palestinian flag or so 1 scarf
but it is not allowed for example Hammers
or to write something else on it.
This is a criminal offense.
What is still a criminal offense
burn the Israeli flag for example
or express agitation or hatred towards this flag.